la planta de acero a soft al en la
ciudad portuaria de mariupol bajo el
constante asalto de las fuerzas rusas es
el ultimo bolsón de resistencia
ucraniana en la ciudad desde hace días
los combates ucranianos se han
atrincherado allí
y según las autoridades también miles de
civiles refugiados bajo la fábrica los
soldados asediados escasos de alimentos
lanzaron un llamado desesperado en las
redes sociales para pedir ayuda
nos enfrentamos quizás a nuestros
últimos días sino horas el enemigo nos
superan en número diez a uno muy
disfrutamos
apelamos y suplicamos a todos los
líderes mundiales que nos ayuden les
pedimos que utilicen el procedimiento de
extracción y nos lleven a territorio de
un tercer estado un proyecto del trader
dragón el presidente ucraniano dice que
su petición a rusia de una evacuación no
ha sido atendida lamentablemente no
hemos tenido ninguna respuesta de rusia
a la oferta de intercambio que podría
salvar a los civiles y defensores de
mariupol y este silencio debe ser notado
por todos los que han estado pueden
estar asociados con rusia rusia ha
intensificado sus ataques en todo el
frente del este en su punto de mira
ciudades como es lo bianco trama torch
con esta ofensiva rusia afirma haber
entrado en una nueva fase de guerra
el ejército ruso está llevando a cabo
las tareas establecidas por el jefe del
ejército para la operación militar
especial se están aplicando el plan de
liberación de las repúblicas populares
de donges y lugansk así como las medidas
para restablecer la paz
- rusia sigue lanzando asaltos contra
las demás ciudades asediadas en jarquín
al menos cuatro personas murieron el
martes en bombardeos contra zonas
residenciales